[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابراز العناوين
طريق الدفاع الاوكرانيه تتعهد بعدم
استهداف الاراضي الروسيه بالصواريخ طويله
المدى
وتتوقعه هجوما روسيا هذا الشهر
والقرار الاوروبي فرض سقف جديد لسعر النفط
الروسي يدخل حيز التنفيذ وسط قلق من
اضطرابات في الاسعار
الصين تحمل رئيس هيئه الارصاد لديها
مسؤوليه انحراف في المنطاد والبنتاجون
بامتلاك اسطول من مناطيد التجسس
خامنئي يعفو عن العديد من السجناء بينهم
معتقلون في الاحتجاجات الاخيره منذ مقتل
الشابه مهسا امين
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تعهد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اوليكسي
ريزنكوف بعدم استهداف روسيا بالصواريخ
طويله المدى قائلا ان هذه الصواريخ ستضرب
الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله فقط فيما توقع
هجوما روسيا هذا الشهر كما قال ريزنكوف ان
بلاده بحاجه الى مئات الالاف من الطائرات
المسيره وان العمل جاري لتلبيه تلك
الاحتياجات واكد اهميه دعم سوق المسيرات
الاوكرانيه خاصه التي تستخدم في نطاق واسع
من العمليات جوا بحرا وبرا
واضاف ان مهام تلك الطائرات قد تتعلق
بتعديل نيران المدفعيه وتوصيل معدات
عسكريه واجلاء الجرحى
[موسيقى]
هذا وكشف اعلام اوكرانيه عن اعلان حاله
التاهب الجوي في مقالياف وذلك بعد انباء
عن قصف روسي الى ذلك قال وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اوكسي ريزنكوف ان بلاده بحاجه
الى مئات الالاف من الطائرات المسيره كما
ذكرنا وان العمل جار لتلبيه تلك
الاحتياجات
الكلاب مباشره ومراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه اهلا وسهلا بك جديد اخبار القصف
والشريط الميداني تحديدا المعلومات التي
تصلكم عن المعارك سواء في اوغلي دار او في
بخموت لان القوات الروسيه وكتائب تقول انه
المساله قاب قوسين او ادنى ان تسقط هذه
المدن بيد قوات فاجنر
نعم في الحقيقه ابدا طالب بباخ متحديدا
القوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه اعلنت ونشرت
فيديو لقوات التي حاولت اقتحام مدينه
بخموت واستطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تصط
هذا الهجوم وقالت ان هنالك حوالي 140
قتيلا من القوات الروسيه التي حاولت
الدخول الى هذه المدينه واقتحامها من اصل
200 من الجنود في هذا المحور تحديدا
المعركه شرسه جدا في جميع الاتجاهات الضغط
كبير جدا على القوات الاوكرانيه في داخل
هذه المدينه هي القوات طبعا ما زالت
متحصنه
بمراكز تحصينها ولكن القوات الروسيه
استطاعت ان تحيط بالمدينه من ثلاثه
اتجاهات وتعمقت اكثر لتضيق المساحه في
المدخل والمخرج الوحيد للمدينه من الخلف
في اتجاه كروماتورسكو والاتجاه وهذا جعل
الطرق الاستراتيجيه التي يمكن من خلالها
ادخال الامدادات الى القوات الاوكرانيه في
مرمى نيران مدفعيه الق الروسيه لذلك الوضع
صعب جدا في هذا المحور واقر بذلك وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني وكذلك
ذكر ذلك بيان هيئه اركان العامه المشتركه
في اكثر من مره طبعا
هناك القتال يعني القوات الروسيه تلقي
بعدد كبير جدا من الجنود لذلك القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول ان المشكله الاساسيه
والرئيسيه انهم يلقون باعداد هائله من
الجنود لذلك الوضع صعب جدا ولكن ما زالت
الجبهه متماسكه في تلك المنطقه الوجهات
الاساسيه
هيبانسك وبالاضافه الى محور ضخمه هذه
المحاور الاساسيه التي تقوم قوات الاتحاد
الروسي بتنفيذ عمليات نشطه وكثيفه فيها
خلاف ذلك طبعا هنالك فقط قتال بيئه
المدفعيه سواء كان في الجنوب او في
الجبهات الاخرى طالب طيب في حديث الان انه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني تعهد بان صواريخ
هاي مارس واورغان لن ابدا ضد الاراضي
الروسيه الى اي مدى هذا الكلام صحيح وان
هذا التعهد نقل الى موسكو
نعم طبعا هذا التعهد هو للشركاء الذين
الان ما زالوا مترددين في نقل صواريخ
بعيده المدى الى كيف لماذا تحتاج كيف هذه
الصواريخ بعيده المدى لان القوات الاتحاد
الروسي نقلت
المستودعات ابعد من مدى هاي مارس هاي مارس
حتى هذه اللحظه الموجود عند القوات
الاوكرانيه هو مداه 80 كيلو متر وهي نقلت
الان اللوجستيات جميعها الى 120 كيلو متر
ولذلك لا يوجد اي فعاليه للمدفعيه الان
المدفعيه هم لا يضربون بها القوات في
الحدود وانما يضربون بها القوافل يضربون
بها القواعد العسكريه يضربون بها مستودعات
الذخيره ومستودعات الوقود لتصعيب عمليه
الدعم اللوجستي للقوات في الجبهات
المختلفه لذلك الان القوات الدفاع يعني
الجيش الاوكراني يحتاج الى
انظمه اطلاق صواريخ ابعد من 120 كلم لذلك
هي تقوم الان بهذه التعهدات للشركاء بانها
لن تقوم ضرب الاراضي الروسيه طيب يعني
طالما ذكرنا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الحديث
الان يتواتر عن انه سيقال او سيستقيل
الاخبار العاجله تقول الان انه لن يستقيل
الا اذا طلب منه الرئيس في ذلك الى اي مدى
يعني راس وزير الدفاع موضوع على المحك وان
اقالته قال قوسين او ادنى حذيفه اخر
المعلومات
نعم في الحقيقه يعني انا اليوم تحدثت لاحد
المصادر والذي قال لي ان هذا الامر رائع
جدا الان في الداخل ويتم مناقشته كذلك
طبعا اليوم برلمانيين مطلعين جدا احدهما
من حزب الرئيسكي ايضا تحدثوا عن انه هنالك
احتمال
تتم يعني هي ليست اقاله وانما نقل ريزنكوف
في فريق الرئيس سيظل في فريق الرئيس ولكن
سينقل الى منصب اخر وسياتي بودانه رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه في مكان اريزن كفو
ولكن ريزنكا في نفسه يعني اجاب على هذه
التساؤلات وقال انا شخصيا لا اعلم عن اي
اقاله او طلب الاستقاله بخصوصي ولكني في
فريق الرئيس واينما يراني سوف اذهب وقال
على المسؤولين ان يعلموا انهم لن يكونوا
في اي منصب مدى الحياه ويجب ان يخلو
الموقع متى ما طلب منهم ذلك وانا سافعل
ذلك ولكن لدي الكثير مما استطيع ان اقدمه
كانجازات في الفتره الماضيه طيب شكرا لك
حذيفه عادل على كل هذه المتابعه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا ينضم
الي من دونسك مراسل العربيه رائد رغب
الرائد ايضا جديد الاخبار الميدانيه شريط
المعارك تحديدا اوغلي دار
طالب مساء الخير بالفعل يعني
تستعر المعارك في محور
جنوبا وشمالا حيث اجلادار وباخ لكن الاكثر
سخونه هو باخمه قوات فاجنر ما زالت تطوق
المدينه تحاول توسيع الطوق من الناحيه
الشماليه الغربيه ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه من الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه تكاد
تصل الى مدينه قسطنطين حيث سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا ومن الناحيه الشماليه
تكاد تصل ايضا الى مدينه سلافيانس الدائره
اصبحت يعني شبه كامله الا ممرات قليله
يمكن ان يستطيع منها الجيش الاوكراني
الانسحاب او الدعم بامدادات عسكريه خفيفه
وليست ثقيله لان هناك فيديوهات اظهرت سحب
الجيش الاوكراني لالياته الثقيله من مدينه
باقمه طبعا هذه الفيديوهات عب
بلده تيفانا او مدينه ايفانا وتتقدم ايضا
للوصول الى بلدات اخرى
والاله العسكريه الروسيه تقصف بعنف ان كان
براجمات الصواريخ او من مدافع يعني بات
الوضع صعب جدا جدا على الجيش الروسي طبعا
الجانب الاوكراني ايضا عفوا على الجيش
الاوكراني والجانب الاوكراني يؤكد هذا ان
كان من الرئيس ليلينسكي او من حتى
القيادات العسكريه في الداخل هي مساله وقت
سيطره الجيش الروسي على مدينه باخموت
وانسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه هناك ايضا
مصادر تشير الى تعزيز القوات الاوكرانيه
لقدرات العسكريه في اوغلادار حيث ان جيش
الروسي يستخدم نفس الاستراتيجيه وهي تطويق
المدن يطوق الجيش الروسي مدينه غلادار
جنوب المقاطعه طبعا طالب الان يطوق
المدينه من
النواحي يعني الجنوبيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
وجنوبيه الغربيه على شكل هلال او نصف
دائره القوات الاوكرانيه تزيد بتحصيناتها
بدعم عسكري بالاليات
يعني بالمكونات البشريه الجنود الاوكرانيه
الروس يقولون بان
وبدقيقه وبعجاله طالب يقولون بان المناطق
الصناعيه في المحور الجنوبي هي محصنه جيدا
بانفاق تحت الارض على شاكله ازوفيستال
سيكون صعب جدا اختراق مدينه اوغلادار
سيستهلك يعني العمليات سؤال سؤال اخير لو
سمحت لي فيه يعني كلام وزير الدفاع الان
التعهد بانه صواريخ هاي مارس واورغان
بعيده المدى لن تستخدم لم تستخدم ابدا ضد
الاراضي الروسيه هل تاخذ موسكو والجيش
الروسي هذه التصريحات بعين الاعتبار يعني
وتطمنه هذه التصريحات ام لا هذا لن يغير
شيئا طالما حتى ان هذه الصواريخ اذا ضربت
المقاطعات الاربعه في دوناتس ستعتبرها
موسكو يعني ضمن الاراضي الروسيه
طالب لا بد من الاشاره الى ان القوه
الاوكرانيه تبعد عن مكان اخراجنا لهذا
المباشر ست او سبعه كيلو مترات من هنا لا
اكثر خلف بيسكي التي سيطر عليها الجيش
الروسي او القوات المواليه لروسيا تبعد من
هنا ثلاثه كيلومترات وبعدها منطقه حيث
القوات الاوكرانيه بالامس استانفت القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفها للمدينه هنا في دانيتك
اربعه قتلى وعده اصابات المسافه ما بين
تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه لا يزيد عن عشرات
الكيلومترات وما بين القوات الروسيه التي
تعتبر اقرب ايضا من المدنيين اذا تحدثنا
عن المدنيين هنا سته او سبعه كيلومترات
فان القوات الروسيه تكون اقرب الى امتار
قليله يعني عفوا كيلومترات قليله طيب
بالفعل يعني المدى الطويل الصواريخ طويله
المدى من الطبيعي انها تستهدف القرم التي
تعتبرها روسيا اراضي روسيه بينما يعتبرها
وزير الخارجيه او الدفاع الاوكرانيه
يعتبرونها اراضي اوكرانيا وانها ستكون
داخل محور المعارك وذلك ما دفع القياده
الروسيه
اكد بان دوله نوويه لن يعني لن تصمت على
اي اعتزال على اراضي ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
دونيس مراسل العربيه اراد الاكبر شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه
في شان متصل دخل القرار الاوروبي فرضا سقف
جديد لسعر النفط والمنتجات النفطيه
الروسيه حيز التنفيذ اليوم بموافقه مجموعه
السبع واستراليا وزاره الطاقه المجريه
حذرت من حدوث عجز في الكميات المطلوبه من
الوقود في اوروبا وقالت الوزاره ان شراء
الاتحاد الاوروبي للمنتجات النفطيه من
مصادر اخرى كند والشرق الاوسط والصين بسبب
العقوبات على روسيا قد يسبب اضطرابا في
امن الطاقه لبعد تلك المصادر وغلاء
اسعارها
القرار الذي وافق عليه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعه السبع واستراليا سيفرض حضرا على
شركات الاتحاد الاوروبي التي تقوم
بالتقديم خدمات لنقل وتمويل البضائع
المتجهه الى ثلث البلاد المتعاقده على
شراء المنتجات النفطيه الروسيه باسعار
اعلى من الحد المسموح به روسيا ردت بحظر
توريد النفط والمنتجات البتروليه الى
الدول التي تفرض سقفا سعريا
ومنذ بدايه ديسمبر من عام 2022 فرض
الاتحاد الاوروبي حضرا على الخامه الروسي
المنقول عن طريق البحر
وسقفا على سعر النفط الروسي عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل واعتبارا من اليوم سوف يمتد هذا
الحظر ليشمل شراء المنتجات النفطيه
المكرره الروسيه مع امل بروكسل في ان تؤدي
القيود التي تفرضها الى خفض صادرات النفط
الروسيه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بنسبه 90%
والتي خلصت بالفعل حصه الغاز الروسي في
وارداتها من اكثر من اربعين في المئه الى
اقل من 15% منذ حرب اوكرانيا
قلق متزايد في اسواق الطاقه من اضطراب في
الاسعار خلال الاشهر المقبله بعد ان فرضت
الدول الغربيه عقوبات جديده على قطاع
النفط والغاز الروسي فاليوم يطبق الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا سقفا
سعريا على مشتقات روسيا النفطيه السقف
السعري تم تحديده على اساس مئه دولار
للبرميل من المشتقات النفطيه ذات العلاوه
السعريه مثل الديزل وخمسه واربعون دولارا
للبرميل للمشتقات النفطيه الاقل جوده
والذي يتم تداولها بخصم مثل زيت الوقود
والنفته ومن المقرر ان تتم مراجعه هذا
السقف في مارسا المقبل
هذه العقوبات ليست الاولى على قطاع الطاقه
الروسي فقد طبقت الدول الغربيه في ديسمبر
الماضي حذرا على النفط الروسي المنقول
بحرا ووضعت ايضا سقفا سعريا عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل لصادره خام اليورال كل ذلك للحد
من عائداتها بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
فالاتحاد الاوروبي قدر بان السقوف السعريه
تكلف روسيا 175 مليون دولار يوميا اردت
روسي جاء بوقف توليد النفط من بدايه الشهر
الحالي للدول التي فرضت سقفا سعريا حتى
يوليو المقبل وبدوره قال نائب رئيس
الوزراء الكسندن ان تلك الخطوه تاتي للحد
من تاثير تلك الادوات على اسواق النفط
التي تشهد حاله من عدم اليقين مع ما يمر
به الاقتصاد العالمي من تحديات
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
عمان لان الدكتور عامر الشوبكي وهو الباحث
في شؤون النفط والطاقه دكتور عامر هل من
السهل على هذه الدول الان تطبيق هذا
القرار على ارض الواقع بمعنى ستلتزم
ستلتزم هذه الدول بتطبيقه بحذافيره ام لا
يعني ما يتم الاعلان عن التوافق عليه يعني
على الطاوله هو غير ما هو تحت الطاوله
دعم طالب تحيه لك وشكرا على الاستضافه
يعني من الواضح بانه حسب ايضا ما طبق على
النفس سيطبق على المنتجات النفطيه تسعين
الى 95% من البنيه التحتيه وشركات التامين
تتحكم بها
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا على وجه
الخصوص لذلك لو اتوقع عين منفذ بنفس
الاليه التي تمت على النفط ننفذ تنفذ هذه
الاليه على المنتجات النفطيه لكن الامر
ربما مختلف واثار مختلفه ستكون ربما
كارثيه على الاتحاد الاوروبي بكلف طاقه
اعلى حيث ان السعي الاوروبي الان بتخفيض
معدلات التضخم واسعار الطاقه منها لكن
الان يبدو انهم سيشترون طاقه باسعار
مرتفعه والتاثير سيكون ايضا اقل حده على
روسيا من ناحيه اخرى
السقوف التي وضعت على سعر المنتجات سواء
البنزين او الديزل المرتفع الثمن
والنبته وزيت الوق الثمن هو يباع اصلا في
اقل من هذه الاسعار
ستكون كارثيه على الدول الاوروبيه طيب
لماذا هذه الدول الاوروبيه اذا مجبره على
التقيد بهذه السقوف ام لا هي تقول علنا
شيء ولكن عند التطبيق سيكون لها راي اخر
تحديدا هنغاريا صربيا
نعم صحيح التطبيق الان ايضا سيكون مختلف
يعني نفس ما حدث في موضوع النفط الان
المنتجات النفطيه ستذهب ولن يعرف مصدرها
الى هند الى تركيا الى دول اخرى تنتظر
لترفع مكاسبها المغرب ايضا من هذه الدول
التي او رفعت مستورداتها من المنتجات
الروسيه في محاوله اعاده بيعها مره اخرى
الى دول اوروبيه في نهايه المطاف ستصل الى
اوروبا باسعار مرتفعه وسيذهب فارق السعر
الى هذه الدول فاعتقد بان هنالك مفارقه في
الخطوه الاوروبيه وهذا ايضا يحدث نوعا ما
في النفط الذي يذهب كمنتجات نفطيه مكرره
الى اوروبا مره اخرى بعد حظره الان ايضا
المنتجات النفطيه التي من المتوقع ان طبعا
ستتزامن مع مرسوم الرئيس الروسي بوتين
الذي نفذ في الاول من فبراير بمنع بيع
المنتجات والنفط على الدول تقبل في السقوف
السعريه هذا الامر ايضا ربما يؤدي في
مرحله ما اذا لم تجد روسيا يعني مجالا
لبيع بعض منتجاتها النفطيه الى انخفاض
انتاجها الدكتور عامر انا سمعت احد
المحللين الاوروبيين يعلق على ذلك اليوم
انه مسموح لهذه الدول الاوروبيه ان تشتري
النفط او المشتقات النفطيه من الصين من
الهند ومن غير من البلدان التي هي تشتري
هذه المشتقات
والنفط من روسيا بمعنى انه الدول
الاوروبيه تشتري النفط الروسي ولكن الذي
يعبر الى الصين وكانه الامر يعني الواحد
يكذب على نفسه
نعم صحيح هو كذلك لكن يعني ليست بطرق
رسميه هي بالتفاف على العقوبات يقوم بشراء
هذا النفس بمصادر مختلفه بانه مثلا مصدره
الهند او مصدره الصين او مصدره دوله اخرى
يعني من الصعب تحديد مصدر المنتج النفطي
اذا كان هنالك سهوله في تحديد مصدر النفط
لكن ايضا من الصعب تحديد مصدر نفسه اذا
كان ممزوج بنفوت اخرى فهذا الامر يعني هو
بالفعل هو كالذي يضحك على نفسه بالنسبه
للقاره الاوروبيه في هذا الحجر او ربما
لحرمان روسيا من بعض
الايراداتفي بهذا القدر دكتور عامر الشبكي
البحث في شؤون النفط والطاقه من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
النظام في ايران يفرض رسوما على القبور
والقرار يثير غضب الايرانيين
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اقاله السلطات الصينيه رئيس هيئه
الارصاد الجويه في البلاد وحملته مسؤوليه
انحراف المنطاد الى الولايات المتحده ياتي
ذلك فيما اتهم مسؤول في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البينتاجون الصين بانها تمتلك
اسطولا من مناطيض المراقبه والتجسس في
سماء خمس قارات وقال المسؤول الامريكي
لوكاله رويترز ان المنطقه الصيني الذي
اسقطه الجيش الامريكي هو واحد من ذلك
الاسطول واضاف ان المنطاد لم يكن مرتبطا
بالارصاد الجويه بل ارادت الصين استخدامه
للتجسس على مواقع عسكريه حساسه
مسؤولون امريكيون رفيع المستوى كشف ان
المنطقه الصيني تم استهدافه بامر من
الرئيس جو بايدن وذلك من قبل مقاتله من
طراز اف 22 تابعه للقياده الشماليه
الامريكيه التي اطلقت الصاروخا واحدا من
دون وقوع اضرار جانبيه او ضرر للمدني
المنطاد بدات بعد ان قضت ثمانيه ايام في
السفر الى نورس كارولاينا
قبل اسقاطه فوق المحيط الاطلسي
في البدايه دخل المنطاد الصيني منطقه
التعريف الجوي الامريكيه وتحديدا باحدى
جزر الاسكا في الثامن والعشرين من يناير
ثم دخل الى المجال الجوي الكندي في
الثلاثين من يناير حيث ساهمت كندا في
عمليه التتبع المنطاد الصيني وفق
البنتاجون ليعاود الدخول الى المجال الجوي
الامريكي مره اخرى وهو يشق طريقه الى
السماء فوق مدينه
بولايه مونتانا ومن ثم الى ولايه اينهوف
في الحادثين من يناير ليتم بعد ذلك اسقاط
المنطقه الصيني على بعد سته اميال اي ما
يعادل 9.6 كم من ساحل ساوث كارولينا
الامريكيه فيما يمتد حجم الحطام على مساحه
سبعه اميال ما يعادل 11.2 كيلو متر
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا الموضوع مع من
واشنطن الان الدكتور عقيل عباس وهو الخبير
في الشؤون السياسيه ذكر عقيل اهلا وسهلا
بك الى نشره الخامسه هل كانت ردت الفعل
الامريكيه ازاء المنطاد مبالغا فيها بشكل
كبير وهل ما جرى ينقل التوتر الى امريكا
الصيني الى مستوى اعلى في الايام المقبله
شكرا لك على هذه الاستضافه لا اعتقد ان رد
الفعل الامريكي مبالغ به هذه المره هناك
تاريخ للصين في القيام بمثل هذه الفعاليات
في عهد الرئيس ترامب يعني ارسلت الصين
في اوقات متفرقه ولم يكن هناك رد من اداره
ترامب في حينها لم يمر البالون او يغطي
اراض امريكيه شاسعه او يمر فوق يعني
مؤسسات عسكريه حساسه حاول بعضها لكن هذه
المره العمليه مختلفه واسعه ويبدو ان
الصين تريد ان تقيس رد الفعل الاميركي
تتصور ان الولايات
لم تقم لم يكن لديها رد فعل حاسم في
المرتين السابقتين هذه المره ربما تمضي
الامور على النحو الذي مضت فيه الامور في
المرتين الماضيتين لكن كان رد الفعل
الامريكي مختلفا مره هذا المنطاد على
مؤسسات نوويه امريكيه حساسه على مناطق
عسكريه بس دكتور دكتور عقيل مع يعني اسمح
لي بهذا السؤال وهو اكيد اكثر من محلل
عسكري رد على الخطوه الامريكيه بضرب
المنطاد هم يقولون انه لو كانت الصين تريد
ان تتجسس على الولايات المتحده وبالطبع
الدول تتجسس يعني مثل الصين تتجسس على
الولايات المتحده
تتجسس على الصين المساله يعني مش بمنطاد
يعني هائل جدا بهذا الحجم يمكن رؤيته
بالعين المجرده ويسير الاف الكيلومترات
ثمانيه ايام يعني لو كان في التجسس كانت
يعني بوسائل يعني اكثر تطورا مش بمنطاد
بهذا الشكل
هذا هو السؤال الذي يثار في الولايات
المتحده عاده المناطيد ليست هي الوسائل
الفعاله للتجسس لكنها ايضا وسائل رخيصه
مقارنه باجهزه تجسس او ادوات تجسس اخرى
طبعا هذا يعتمد على طريقه التفكير الصينيه
يعني عندما يحلل الامريكيون هذا المنطاد
ويظهر انه فعلا فيه ادوات للتجسس طريقه
حركته يعني كما يقول المختصون تشير الى
انه منطاد تجسس قدره التحكم عاليه في
حركته ياخذ زوايا ينحني ليريد ان يمر على
اماكن معينه بنفس بذاتها بمعنى هناك قصدي
ما اذا ظهر فعلا انه يعني معبا باجهزه
التجسس كما هو التصور الاميركي فحين سيكون
على الصين ان تقدم الاجوبه على هذه
الاسئله انا اعتقد اكو سياق او الساعه
يعني الصين فعلى مدى السنوات الماضيه في
امام المحاكم الامريكيه نت
حدث ثم
انيه تجسس لرعايه صينيين او امريكيين من
اصل صيني عاده تتعلق بقضايا
بس ولكن ولكن البعض يتساءل كمان انه
التغطيه الاعلام الامريكي
لما يسمى بمنطاد التجسس الصيني بهذا الشكل
على مدى ثلاثه ايام والتي وصفت بانها
هستيريا يعني انه الولايات المتحده يعني
تحت القصف كان الولايات المتحده تعد الراي
العام الامريكي لخطوات تصعيديه ما تجاه
الصين وهذا الهدف من كل ما جرى لعمليه
المنطاد
يعني انا بتصوري الاعلام الامريكي اهتم
بها اهتم بها كثيرا قد يكون الاهتمام
مبالغنا الى حد ما لكن علينا ان ننظر الى
الصين في الولايات المتحده ليس لدى الصين
اصدقاء حقيقيين في الولايات المتحده
الحزبان الجمهوري والديمقراطي لديهما اراء
سلبيه بخصوص الصين
عموما يعتقد ان الصين تحاول ان تسرق
معلومات امريكيه في سياقات مختلفه وهذا
يعود منذ التسعينات يعني عدم وجود قانون
صيني صارم بخصوص الملكيه الفكريه
المحاولات الصينيه المستمره لسرقه معلومات
تقنيه امريكيه حساسه فانا اعتقد في اطار
هذا السياق
حق الامريكيين ان يقلقوا هل هناك اجراءات
تصعيديه لا اعتقد انه سيكون هناك اجراء
ات تصحي بالمعنى العسكري وانما بالمعنى
الدبلوماسي نعم
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من واشنطن الدكتور عقيل
عباس الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
وصل وزير الخارجيه روسيس الى العراق في
زياره رسميه على راس وفيديو رسمي يلتقي
خلالها عدد من المسؤولين العراقي ومن
المنتظر ان يلتقي مع نظيره العراقي فؤاد
حسين
ويناقش معه جمله من الملفات منها الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه ودور العراق في
ضمان هذا الاستقرار كما سيبحث الوفد
الروسي مع المسؤولين العراقيين ملف النفط
والغاز ووضع الشركات الروسيه وكذلك ملف
التعاون العسكري
من بغداد لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذه
الزياره ينضم الي من هناك مراسل العربيه
سامر الكبيسي سامر اهلا وسهلا بك ما الذي
يحمله وزير الخارجيه الروسي الى القياده
العراقيه وابرز ما في جدول اعمال هذه
المحادثه
في البدايه مساء الخير ربما بعد ساعه او
ساعتين من الان سيكون وزير الخارجيه
في بغداد هذه الزياره تاتي بحسب بيان
وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه لتاكيد العلاقات
الثنائيه بين العراق وروسيا لكن مصدر في
وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه اكد للعربيه بان
هذه الزياره سيكون اهم ملفات التي سيطرحها
على القياده العراقيه بعد لقاء طبعا يوم
غد من المقرر يوم غد ان يكون هناك مؤتمر
صحفي بين لافاروف وبين نظيره العراقي فؤاد
حسين اضافه الى مجموعه من اللقاءات مع
الرئاسات الثلاث لكن يعني من المقرر بحسب
المصدر من الخارجيه ان تكون الزياره تحمل
ملفين مهمين ربما هي الطاقه والاستثمار
هذا ربما الملفات الابرزان حتى الساعه
بحسب مصدر من الخارجيه سيكون من ضمن الوفد
ممثلين عن الشركات النفطيه والغازيه
الروسيه ربما لبحث الاستثمارات في الطاقه
هنا في العراق اضافه الى طبعا بعض الملفات
التي تخص استقرار المنطقه بحسب بيان وزاره
الخارجيه العراقيه هل هنالك يعني بتعرف في
جدول عام موضوع التعاون العسكري وعقود
التسليح هل هنالك عقود موضوعه على الطاوله
في مخص تسليح الجيش العراقي باسلحه روسيه
يا سامر
اعلن التلفزيون رسمي الايرانيه ان المرشد
الاعلى علي خامنئي اصدر عفوا عن عشرات
الالاف من السجناء من ضمنهم العديد من
المعتقلين في الاحتجاجات التي تعم البلاد
منذ مقتل الشابه مهساه امينه وقالت وسائل
الاعلامي الرسميه ايرانيه ان العفو سيشمل
السجناء الذين لا يواجهون اتهامات بالتجسس
لصالح جهات اجنبيه او بوجود صله مباشره
تربطهم بعملاء في الخارج او بتعمد القتل
او التسبب في الاصابه او بالتسبب في دمار
واحراق ممتلكات الدوله او من لا يوجد ضده
مدعا خاص
وكانت السلطات قد اعتقلت نحو 20 الف شخص
في الاحتجاجات حسب وكاله انباء نشطاء حقوق
الانسان هرانا
وبعد وقت قصير من اعلان الافراج عن الاف
المعتقلين على خلفيه الاحتجاجات افادت
وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه بان السلطات اعتقلت
الصحفيه ايناس محمد والتي تعمل في احدى
المؤسسات الاعلاميه التابعه للاصلاحيين
دون توضيح سبب الاعتقال علما ان الناس هي
الشقيقه التوام للصحفيه الهي محمد
المعتقله بتهمه التامر ضد الامن القومي
بعد نشرها خبر وفاه الفتاه الكرديه مهسا
امين والتي تسبب مقتلها باحتجاجات كبيره
كما اصدر القضاء حكما بالسجن سنه واحده
بحق الصحفي حسين يزدي الموقوف في اصفهان
لتصل قائمه الصحفيين المعتقلين على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات في ايران الى ثلاثين صحفيا
بمناسبه الذكرى السادسه لوفاه الرئيس
الايراني الاسبق اكبر هاشمي رفسا جاني
اكدت عائلته ان وفاته مريبه وطالبت النظام
في ايران باعاده التحقيق حول اسباب الوفاه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس
عائله رفسانجاني تؤكد مقتله وان وفاته لم
تكن طبيعيه
فاطمه هاشمي رفسان ابنه رفسانجاني والدي
شهيد وعرج مظلوما بابا
ترى اليوم والدي شهيد وعرج مظلوما نحن لا
نعيش اياما جيده ونحن في وضع سيء للغايه
والشعب الايراني مكتئب وحزين ويائس بسبب
الازمات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه
9 يناير 2018 ياسر رفسان نجل الرئيس
الاسبق طالب باعاده التحقيق حول اسباب
الوفاه
الخامس عشر من يناير 2022
محسن هاشمي نجلو راسا جاني وفاه والدي
مريبه والنظام اراد اظهار العكس
[موسيقى]
نبقى في ايران حيث عم غضب عارم في الصحافه
المحليه ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بعد
تطبيق طهران لقرار الرسوم على القبور الذي
يدخل حيز التنفيذ في الواحد والعشرين من
مارس المقبل وبحسب المنتقلين فانه من غير
المقبول ان تضطر عائلات الموتى لدفع مثل
هذه الرسوم للتعويض عن عدم قدره المسؤولين
على السيطره على الازمه الماليه وفق ما
نقلته وكاله الانباء الالمانيه
النقاد يقولون انه على النظام في ايران
احترام الموتى وعدم استخدامهم لملا خزانته
الفارغه وتحقيق مصدر جديد للربح مع مرور
البلاد بازمه اقتصاديه حاده
ووفق تقارير اعلاميه ستبلغ قيمه الرسوم ما
يعادل 4.32 دولار تدفع سنويا وليس لمره
واحده مع مخاوف من احتمال بيع القبور التي
لم يتم سداد رسومها من جانب مجلس البلديه
وبالتالي حرمان كثير من الاشخاص من مثواهم
الاخير
ضمن تغطيتنا الخاصه للاحزاب الايرانيه
المعارضه التقت العربيه بمتظاهرات انضممنا
حديثا الى حزب الحريه الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض تركنا خلفهن عائلتهن وقصصا
ماساويه ميديا فتاه تعرضت للاعتقال
والتعذيب لتعترف بشيء لم ترتكبه واخرى
تروي قصه ابنه عمها التي اغتصبها سجنوها
امام اخيها حسب ما تقول
الوجهه موقع ما على اطراف كردستان العراق
بلغنا بعنوانه قبل لحظات فقط من بدء
رحلتنا
[موسيقى]
تبين ان هذه ليست الوجهه النهائيه كان
علينا السير على الاقدام مسافه الى مكان
اخر يرفضن ذكر اي تفاصيل حوله
يقلن ان هذا لضمان امنهن فهذا معسكر هنا
الجديد
وياملنا ان يبقى سريا
[موسيقى]
لدينا قوات متمركزه في منطقه بردي على
الخطوط الاماميه كانت لدينا قوات عسكريه
نسائيه تمركزت هناك ايضا بعدها هجمات
النظام الايراني بالصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره تم نقلنا الى هذه المنطقه
المقاتلات الموجودات هنا يمثلنا ثلث
المقاتلات داخل الحزب لدينا وحدات عسكريه
للمقاتلات في موقعين اخرين تضم هذه
الوحدات اكثر من 200 مقاتله
[موسيقى]
فتاه يتبعن لحزب تحرير كردستان المعروف
اختصارا بيباك احد احزاب المعارضه الكرديه
الايرانيه النشطه في الخارج
يتوزعن على ثلاثه مواقع للتدريب والتدريب
هنا يقصد به رياضات قتاليه
والسلاحا ومحاضرات عن السياسه والحقوق
مهسى
التي اثار مقتلها مظاهرات في ايران لا
تزال تلهم الكثير من الفتيات والنساء
اللواتي تؤمن بشعار المراه الحياه الحريه
بعضهن عجزنا عن البقاء في ايران بعد ان
شاركنا في مظاهرات وتعرضنا للتهديد ربما
حتى للاعتداء من قبل الامن الايراني
فانتقلنا الى هنا الى كردستان العراق
في هذا الموقع وجوه على ملامح الترقب
واخرى وشحط اللثام وهنا قصه مختلفه فتيات
كنا بالامس القريب في شوارع المدن
الايرانيه يتظاهرنا قررنا المغادره لكنهن
يخشين على عائلاتهم اذا ما تعرفت عليهن
استخبارات النظام الايراني
لمشارك في الاحتجاجات فقط بل كنت قائده
لها لكن لم يعد بامكان العيش هناك بحريه
لان القوات الايرانيه تعرفت علي وحكم علي
بالسجن في اليوم الاول الذي عدنا فيه من
جنازه جينا امين الى مدينه سلندر اجتمعنا
في ميدان اقبال كنا نردد شعارات مثل
المراه الحياه الحريه جاءت قوات النظام
لتفريقنا باستخدام الهروات واحتجزون جميعا
تقريبا واخذونا الى مقرهم تعرضت للتعذيب
تضمن ذلك الضربه والصعقه بالكهرباء وادوات
اخرى يتعاطفن
وان كنا يقولن انهن شهدنا وسمعنا عن
اخريات قصصهن توازيها او تفوقها الى منه
احدى هذه الحالات كانت ابنه عمي تعرضت
للاغتصاب والاذاء امام شقيقها هناك المئات
من الحالات المماثله هؤلاء الناس يفقدون
الامل ينهارون ولا يمكنهم الاستمرار في
الحياه لقد راينا اعمالا غير انسانيه جدا
من قبل القوات الايرانيه خلال الانتفاضه
الحاليه
انتهى يوم التدريب او يكاد طبقت هذه
الجلسه اليوميه يقولن انها ضروريه ففيها
قليل من الراحه والغناء وكثير من شعارات
الثوره والمراه
صار ابن عشوب العربيه كردستان العراق
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال رئيس حزب
الحريه الكردستاني الايراني المعارض ان
اعلان استقلال كردستان عن ايران حق
سيناضلون من اجله وانهم سيلجؤون لاي وسيله
لضمان استقلال الاكراد يا سينا ودولتي
رقيبه سمحت القوانين الدوليه لكل امه وشعب
بتقرير مصيره يتضمن ذلك ايضا انشاء دوله
واعلان الاستقلال لدينا خبره 100 عام مع
الدوله الفارسيه طوال ذلك الوقت لم نرى اي
فرصه للعيش في ظل قواعد ديمقراطيه مع
طهران اعلان الاستقلال حقنا لاننا امه
وشعب يحق لنا المطالبه بالاستقلال لذلك
نعتقد انه فقط من خلال الاستقلال يمكننا
تحقيق التنميه في بلدنا هذا حقنا ونحن
نناضل من اجل ذلك امثله في كندا واسكتلندا
في بريطانيا امثله جيده للاتفاق مع الدوله
المركزيه
من اجل اجراء استفتاء في كردستان اذا سمحت
الحكومه بذلك فهي طريقه ديمقراطيه ونحن
نرحب بهذه الخطوه ولكن اذا لم يكن ذلك
مسموحا به فسنستخدم اي وسيله اخرى لضمان
هذا الحق نحن على ثقه من اننا سنحقق هذا
الهدف
نشط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستولي على وظائف جديده
من البشر بينها الصحافه
اهلا بكم من جديد افادت وسائل الاعلام
باكستانيه محليه بان الرئيس الباكستاني
السابق برويز مشرف توفي بعد معاناه طويله
مع المرض
يذكر ان مشرف كان الرئيس العاشر لباكستان
وشغل ايضا منصب الرئيس لهيئه الاركان
المشتركه لباكستان من العام
1998 حتى العام 2001
مشرف رئيس باكستان السابق تولى السلطه بعد
انقلاب ابيض عام
نصب نفسه رئيسا في يونيو 2001 وحكم
باكستان لقرابه 10 سنوات
نجا من ثلاث محاولات اغتيال دبرها تنظيم
القاعده عام 2008 خسر حزب مشرف الانتخابات
وغادر البلاد ليعيش فتره في المنفى
ببريطانيا
عاد مشرف الى باكستان عام 2013 لخوض
الانتخابات البرلمانيه تم منعه من
المشاركه بعد تراكم القضايا القانونيه ضده
رفع حظر السفر عنه في 2016 وتوجه الى دبي
ليتلقى العلاج وبقي هناك الى وفاته عن عمر
ناهز تسعه وسبعين عاما
خص بعض الخبراء عددا من المهمات والوظائف
الاكثر عرضه للزوال وتوليها من قبل ادوات
الذكاء الاصطناعي على المدى القريب
لنتعرف على ابرزها
الذكاء الاصطناعي يهدد بعض الوظائف
الوظائف التقنيه مثل البرمجه وتطوير
التطبيقات وتحليل البيانات
وظائف الاعلام مثل انشاء المحتوى والكتابه
الفنيه والصحافه
الوظائف القانونيه مثل مساعد قانوني
الوظائف التسويقيه مثل باحث في التسويق
والاعلانات
الوظائف الماليه مثل المستشار المالي
والمحلل المالي الوظائف التعليميه مثل
المعلمون
نشره الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيبه تحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]